au plus haut depuis le mois de mai 1
4897 nouveaux cas ont été enregistrés
aujourd'hui pour freiner la propagation
du virus le port du masque devient
obligatoire dans plus de douze mille
vies
ici au mali 2e journée de pourparlers
entre les militaires insurgés la
délégation envoyée par les pays de la
cedeao
des discussions doivent aussi s'engager
avec les cinq membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu la good
luck john attah médiateur attitré de la
cedeao s'est dit optimiste
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur rt france
des dizaines de milliers de manifestants
aujourd'hui à minsk en biélorussie
contre le président réélu il y a quinze
jours alexandre loukachenko au pouvoir
depuis 26 ans
c'est la première fois que le chef
d'état fait face à une telle
contestation dans son pays
il a d'ailleurs promis de régler le
problème l'armé est actuellement en état
d' alerte la démobilisation qui ne
faiblissent pas depuis sa réélection est
les soutiens du président se mobilise
également les derniers détails avec
david laws in me ils sont des milliers
dans les rues depuis deux semaines dans
le pays
des mobilisations contre le gouvernement
abyss
des manifestants protestent contre la
réélection d'un président qu'ils
estiment illégitime
après plusieurs jours d'affrontements et
de répression violente les
contestataires espèrent un changement
pour leur pays
nous sommes ici avec toutes les filles
pour montrer que nous sommes contre la
violence le mensonge et l'illégalité
les autorités ne devraient pas être
comme ça tous les candidats ont été
emprisonnés pour des raisons politiques
il a fait une erreur et n'a laissé que
svetlana tirs à 9 callas il pensait
qu'elle était une simple femme au foyer
et que rien ne se passerait mais les
gens ont pris une décision ils ont voté
pour elle tout le monde sait qu'elle a
gagné et qu'il a perdu je suis choqué
par ces mensonges et ces violences qui
règne dans notre pays
j'ai trois enfants et trois
petits-enfants je veux qu'ils vivent
dans un pays livres qu'ils aient la
liberté d'exprimer leurs opinions et
d'avoir de belles perspectives de vie
des manifestations également en soutien
au pouvoir
de son côté le président loukachenko a
ordonné à son ministre de la défense de
prendre des mesures plus strictes pour
défendre l'intégrité territoriale du
pays
je charge le commandement opérationnel
en charge des frontières occidentales de
surveiller de la manière la plus stricte
les mouvements de toutes les unités
militaires des pays voisins membres de
l'otan je charge le comité national des
frontières de renforcer la sécurité sur
tout le périmètre des frontières de
l'état contrôlé chaque personne qui
vient ici à des fins illégales
pas un seul combattant pas insolent
provocateur pas une seule cartouche ne
doit pénétrer sur notre territoire
une situation politique tendue dont
l'issue reste incertaine lundi le
secrétaire d'état américain adjoint
stéphane big n se rendra en lituanie
pays où la principale candidate de
l'opposition svetlana terra nova scotia
s'est réfugié depuis maintenant plus de
dix jours et une chaîne humaine
symbolisant le soutien des états voisins
à la biélorussie a commencé à se former
à la frontière du pays elle doit
parcourir à 34 km pour relier la
capitale lituanienne
villemus pour rejoindre les portes de la
biélorussie au total quelques 58
participants sont attendus à l'événement
d'autres chaînes humaines sont prévus
dans la capitale estonienne à tallinn ou
encore à prague en république tchèque
à paris également une chaîne humaine a
été organisée dans les jardins du
trocadéro comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images on soutient toujours aux
manifestants et puis jean de gliniasty
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
ancien ambassadeur de france à moscou
était avec nous sur notre antenne tout à
leur écoute et ajustements son analyse
de la situation en biélorussie
ça fait très longtemps qu'il ya une
opposition assez puissante à loukachenko
installé dans les vie intellectuelle et
toute la classe moyenne éduquée
en revanche ces campagnes elles étaient
plutôt pro loukachenko et les villes et
les usines étaient provocation co c'est
équilibre c'est évidemment aiguisé si je
puis dire il est devenu beaucoup plus
instable avec des élections ou
loukachenko contre l'évidence a fait 80
% des voix donc maintenant on est un peu
dans une sorte d'impasse puisque le coup
locasun co son resop à dangers
extérieurs qui manifestement n'existe
pas et plats l'opposition les
manifestants si jusque là du tout anti
russe et qui ne le sont pas mais quand
même si rennes au sky a est réfugié en
lituanie elle va rencontrer le stade et
américains les français les allemands
dans la voix elle est écoutée en europe
que j'ai de très très prudents jusqu'à
présent et tout le monde considère en
tout cas en europe que les russes
doivent jouer un rôle important pour
régler cette affaire
paris retient son souffle ce soir avec
la finale de la ligue des champions de
football entre le paris saint-germain et
le bayern munich et qui se déroule dans
une heure à lisbonne après à des ré
détention lors de la victoire en
demi-finale mardi dernier elle
d'importants moyens de sécurité vont
être déployés ce soir dans la capitale
avec un double objectif sanitaires et
d'ordre public
3000 membres des forces de l'ordre sont
mobilisés et seront épaulés de 3,0 en
sapeurs pompiers et dix sept stations de
métro sont fermées il n'y aura plus de
circulation sur les champs-elysées dans
une heure les rassemblements sont
interdits seront interdits deux ans
après le match à noter aussi que des
contrôles du port du masque seront
régulièrement effectués dans les bars et
établissements qui retransmettront à la
rencontre à bhl le coronavirus lui
continue de se propager en france
olivier vers on reconnaît une situation
à risque dans un entretien accordé à nos
confrères du jdd le ministre de la santé
exclut tout de même l'idée d'art
confinement aujourd'hui 4897 nouveaux
diagnostics positifs ont été enregistrés
selon les autorités sanitaires
32 nouveau cluster ont été identifiés
depuis le début de la semaine le nombre
de contaminations ne cesse d'augmenter
néanmoins le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées à stable tout comme celui
à des malades placés en réanimation
nous sommes dans une situation à risque
ce n'est pas une reprise de l'épidémie
parce qu'elle ne s'est jamais arrêté
elle a seulement été contrôlé pendant le
confinement puis le déconfinement
progressif
le risque c'est que après avoir enlevé
doucement le couvercle de la casserole
l'eau se remettent à bouillir ce n'est
pas une exception française
c'est une dynamique européenne à l'heure
où les français rentrent nombreux de
vacances et où il s'interroge sur la
situation épidémique dans notre pays
accorder la priorité aux qu'ovide
consulter l'ensemble des acteurs du pays
prendre le temps d'expliquer accompagner
avant la rentrée scolaire et la reprise
du travail est nécessaire
nous devons veiller à définir et mettre
en place toutes les rênes
les protocoles nécessaires pour que la
rentrée puis se dérouler dans les
meilleures conditions cette lisibilité
nécessaire à la relance
les ponots ministre de la santé qui
assure par ailleurs que la france venait
de dépasser le seuil des 700 mille tests
par semaine parmi les autres mesures
pour endiguer la propagation du virus
le port du masque il est maintenant
obligatoire dans certains lieux publics
de plus de douze mille communes dont
paris rennes nantes ou encore lyon
certaines municipalités elles imposent
même sur l'ensemble de leur territoire
c'est le cas à nice depuis jeudi mais
aussi à toulouse
les détails avec coeur robert harris
objet de toutes les polémiques depuis le
début de la pandémie
le masque fait son grand retour dans les
rues de plus d'un tiers des
municipalités françaises
ce samedi toulouse a fait le show à
détendre le port du masque à l'ensemble
de son territoire
nous avons vu au cours de ces dernières
semaines chaque croître une façon très
rapide la pénétration du virus au sein
de la population toulousaine et c'est ce
qui a conduit avec un dépassement du
seuil d alerte c'est ce qui a conduit à
prendre cette décision
dans la ville rose la décision est
plutôt bien vu par les habitants le port
qui ne se pose pas de questions au
travail c'est pareil donc c'est pareil
d'ailleurs c'est pour la santé de tous
il faut le porter c'est normal et
j'avoue que l'extérieur si elle ne
serait pas trop demande si elle faisait
tout ce en quoi bon après ça va être un
réflexe apprendre à dire au quotidien
non c'est pas très contraignant
c'est un peu chaud mais s'est fait
quelques mois qu'on a l'habitude par un
port du masque qui s'étend à l'intérieur
dès le 1er septembre celui-ci sera
obligatoire en entreprise et dans les
établissements scolaires pour les élèves
de 11 ans et plus un protocole renforcé
pour éviter à un report de la rentrée
comme l'a expliqué le ministre de
l'éducation nationale nous voulons
évidemment que l'éducation soit pour
tous et qu' il n'y ait pas de
renforcement des inégalités ou des
difficultés scolaires du fait des
circonstances sanitaire donc j'ai deux
impératifs sont complémentaires c'est
protéger tous les élèves et les adultes
mais aussi assurer l'éducation de tous
et c'est un point fondamental c'est
pourquoi la rentrée aura bien lieu comme
prévu le 1er septembre à lille lyon
marseille ou paris
ce sont pour le moment seulement les
zones à forte fréquentation qui font
l'objet de ces mesures sanitaires comme
la butte montmartre où les abords de la
tour eiffel depuis juillet
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
a admis que la transmission du coc u19
par voie aérienne ne peut pas être
exclue et puis recrudescence de cas de
corona virus en corée du sud le pays
n'avait pas connu une telle hausse
quotidienne depuis le début du mois de
mars près de 400 contaminations à ces
dernières 24 heures conséquence le
gouvernement sud coréen a décidé de
durcir les règles de distanciation
physique à séoul et ses environs à
boîtes de nuit bars karaokés ou encore
cybercafé à sont fermés elle les grands
rassemblements sont également interdits
et actions ce dimanche dans les rues de
la capitale sud coréenne
je pense que le port du masque est
impératif j'étais inquiète parce que
quand l'épidémie a eu l'air de recul et
beaucoup de gens non plus porter le
masque correctement ou ne l'ont plus
portée du tout si la distanciation
social est portée au niveau 3 cela
frappera plus durement encore dans
l'entreprise et en dehors des affaires
je suis inquiet pour ma propre santé
il y a tellement d'infection dans les
régions avoisinantes que j'ai
l'impression que je pourrais attrapé le
virus
je pense que la pandémie de kobe 19 se
poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de l'année
prochaine d'ici là il faut continuer à
porter un masque et maintenir une
distanciation sociale et puis ces
chiffres depuis le début de la pandémie
dans le monde huit cent mille personnes
sont décédées ducobu 19 et plus de 23
millions de cas d'infections ont été
enregistrés dans 196 pays et territoires
en inde le seuil des 3 millions qui a
été dépassé plusieurs nations reprennent
donc des mesures restrictives regarder
[Musique]
au mali ce deuxième journée de
pourparlers entre les militaires
insurgés les membres de la délégation de
la cedeao ait des discussions doivent
aussi se tenir avec les cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu le président déchu ben haim
boubacar keïta est lui aussi entendu le
point sur la situation en asie avec
clémence pital une rencontre très
optimiste c'est ainsi que goodluck
johnatan médiateur attitré de la cedeao
résume ses discussions avec les
militaires désormais au pouvoir au mali
la délégation de la communauté des états
de l'afrique de l'ouest mené par
l'ancien président nigérian a été reçu
par les membres du comité national pour
le salut du peuple qui a renversé le
président ibrahim boubacar kéïta mardi
dernier les discussions qui se
poursuivent ce week-end vise un accord
d'ici à lundi
nous avons compris que des chefs d'état
comme l'ivoirien alassane ouattara
travaille pour une décrispation pour une
solution pacifique
même s'ils ont fermement condamné notre
prise de pouvoir nous sommes ouverts aux
discussions
goodluck johnatan a été mandaté par la
cedeao pour assurer un retour immédiat
de l'ordre constitutionnel au mali
l'organisation intergouvernementale
dénonce coup d'état militaire
mais face au soutien populaire et à la
bénédiction du mouvement d'opposition
malien m 5
la cedeao souhaite trouver un compromis
la cedeao a essentiellement port olona
compagne et le mali la solution que nous
devons trouver et je crois que tout le
monde est d'accord c'est une solution
qui satisfasse les maliens d'abord et
qui soit aussi bénéfique pour tous les
pays de la sous région
la délégation de la cedeao s'est aussi
rendu à cathy dans la banlieue de bamako
devenue le fief des militaires au
pouvoir les envoyer ouest africains ont
pu y rencontrer le président déchu
ibrahim boubacar keita ainsi que
d'autres personnalités arrêtées par les
militaires après tous ses contacts
la cedeao a précisé ses objectifs
associer l'ensemble de la classe
politique malienne à la sortie de crise
et veiller au respect des droits de
l'homme dans le pays
aux etats unis la chambre des
représentants a voté une aide de 25
milliards de dollars pour sauver la
poste américaine lui sps est aujourd'hui
au coeur d'un immense enjeu électoral à
donald trump dénonce depuis des semaines
le système de vote par correspondance
dont est responsable le sps le président
américain considère le vote par courrier
comme la plus grande fraude électorale
de l'histoire estime qu'elle peut
favoriser son adversaire joe biden
regarder cette année la poste va
probablement enregistrer une perte de
plus de 9 milliards de dollars
s'il n'ya pas de changement nos pertes
ne feront qu'augmenter dans les années à
venir
[Musique]
et
depuis mon arrivée nous avons déplacé
700 points de collecte du courrier et je
n'avais aucune idée du fait que cela
relevait d'un processus pré établis
quand nous avons découvert cela quand je
les a pris nous nous sommes entretenus
avec l'équipe de direction et là nous
avons constaté à quel point cela faisait
des vagues
alors j'ai décidé d'arrêter ce processus
que nous ne reprendront qu'après
l'élection
[Musique]
mais écoutez maintenant l'analyse de
douglas y est dit ce professeur de droit
et spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines plus protégés comme thibaut
crosse repose sur des montages il très
peu de républicains monde utilisé le
voir correspondante
donc c'est certainement possible et les
boutons démocrate
on essaie de faire tout maintenant pour
gagner l'élection mais derrière ça il y
a aussi une politique plus longue tant
de partis républicains pour détruire la
côte vers un métro faillite pour le
privatiser
à kouba et a donc ces deux politiques
républicaines se conjuguent que
maintenant et c'est encore un sujet
triste voire le mépris de la démocratie
est mis en place pour faire les réformes
ne sont que 1 1 mise
l'empêchement de la voix pour sur
l'élection de 33 à contribuer 10
millions de dollars 140 la guerre
distance entre l'application tik tok et
les états unis continuent le réseau
social n'hésite pas à répliquer en
annonçant vouloir porter plainte contre
le pays dirigé par donald trump dans la
semaine à venir
l entreprise chinoise accuse les
etats-unis de je cite s'immiscer dans
des négociations entre groupes privés
tik tok répond donc aux menaces
d'interdiction du président américain
on le rappelle à l'administration trump
accuse depuis des mois l'application à
d'espionner ses utilisateurs et selon ti
révèle avocats spécialistes du numérique
dans cette guerre économique et
politique donald trump livre à tik tok
c'est le consommateur américain qui sera
le plus lésé à la fin c'est une affaire
prend sous et je crois et david enjeux
politiques et diplomatiques
mais en tout cas elle rompt peut
craindre en tout cas que ce soit
l'internaute qui soit le grand perdant
une nouvelle fois et la liberté
d'expression également 2
de cette affaire qui est absolument
scandaleuse parce qu'utiliser un décret
pour de force utilisée l'urgence
nationale pour simplement des
affirmations qui ne sont absolument pas
démontré qu'ils sont en tout cas utilise
également aux états unis largement pour
détourner les données personnelles de
deux délits utilisateurs tout ça n'est
pas sa seule et le directeur de l agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique se
rendra en diront demain pour
s'entretenir avec les autorités locales
elles ce sera la première fois que
raphaël mariano grossi se rendra en iran
depuis sa prise de fonction c'était en
décembre dernier elle ce déplacement
intervient après le refus des grandes
puissances de l'onu de prolonger des
sanctions internationales contre l'iran
demandée par les états unis à vouvoyer
les précisions de françois xavier
lambert c'est une crise diplomatique qui
n'en finit pas et même à trois mois de
la présidentielle américaine donald
trump a de nouveau ravivé les tensions
entre les etats-unis et l'iran mercredi
dernier l'annoncé son intention de
rétablir la quasi totalité des sanctions
contre la république islamique
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé au secrétaire
d'état mike p o de notifier au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu que les états unis
entendent rétablir pratiquement toutes
les sanctions des nations unies contre
l'iran ce jusque là suspendu le
lendemain de cette annonce le secrétaire
d'état américain si je cite notifier au
conseil de sécurité les violations
présumées des engagements iranien prévu
par l'accord conclu à vienne en 2015
mike pompéo a également accusé les pays
signataires de manquer de fermeté face à
téhéran en refusant de prolonger
l'embargo sur les ventes d'armes à
l'iran
nos actions d'aujourd'hui ne devrait
surprendre personne
notre équipe a déployé tous les efforts
diplomatiques possibles depuis
maintenant près de deux ans pour
renouveler cet embargo sur les armes
aucun pays à l'exception des états unis
nous le courage et la conviction de
proposer une résolution au lieu de cela
ils ont choisi de se ranger du côté des
ayatollahs leurs actions mettent en
danger les populations de lire
du yémen du liban de la syrie même leurs
propres citoyens pour rétablir ces
sanctions les états unis expliquent
qu'ils vont déclencher un mécanisme
appelé snap bac une possibilité offerte
aux participants à l'accord de vienne
qui inclut la chine la russie la france
le royaume uni l'allemagne l'union
européenne et l'iran mais cette
procédure est juridiquement compliqué
validé après le retrait américain de
cette entente en 2018 paris berlin
londres moscou et pékin ont assuré ne
pas soutenir cette initiative américaine
de son côté téhéran assure compter sur
l'onu pour contrer les etats-unis l'iran
attend du secrétaire général et des
états membres du conseil de sécurité
qu'ils s'acquittent de leurs obligations
légales et contre le comportement voyous
de l'administration américaine
les etats-unis ne sont plus signataires
de l'accord sur le nucléaire et la
décision de washington n'a aucun
fondement malgré l'opposition
internationale donald trump pourrait
néanmoins clamé dans un mois que ces
sanctions sont à nouveau en vigueur
contre l'iran le président américain
déjà rétablis depuis 2018 et même durci
toutes les sanctions de washington
contre la république islamique
en riposte les autorités iraniennes
avaient annoncé ne plus respecter leur
engagement de limiter leur programme
nucléaire notamment concernant
l'enrichissement d'uranium et pour
gérard vespière chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
la visite du directeur de l'aiea en iran
a un double objectif
les enjeux sont double premièrement il y
a les écarts que l'iran a commis en
sortant donc des paramètres techniques
enrichissement nombre de centrifugeuses
a donc la russie et la chine demandent à
l'iran de rester dans l'accord et les
trois puissances européennes demandent à
l'iran de revenir à accor donc là ce
sont les caractéristiques techniques de
l'accord et vient se greffer depuis le
mois de mars
la confirmation par là la direction de
l'agencé internationale à l'énergie
atomique qu'il y avait effectivement sur
un site qui n'était pas inspecté à des
traces d'uranium
avec une modification humaine ce n'est
pas de l'uranium de basse et eu de
l'uranium qui avait été transformée par
des procédés physico-chimiques donc
jusqu'à présent l'iran a nié et refuse d
inspection soit installations là donc il
ya ce sujet plus les paramètres autour
de l'accord place maintenant à notre
rubrique art est sur le web une
sélection d'articles à retrouver sur
notre site arte france point tvc des
tensions historiques qui perdure le
mouvement libanais chiite hezbollah a
annoncé avoir abattu samedi un drone
israélien qui franchissaient la
frontière avec le liban a de son côté
l'armée israélienne a bien confirmé
qu'un de leurs drones étaient tombés
dans le territoire libanais
le mouvement chiite avait déjà averti de
possibles représailles terrienne en
septembre 2019 et la sonnette d'alarmé
tirée à part le directeur exécutif du
programme alimentaire mondial paul
beasley demande une aide de 4 9
milliards de dollars pour lutter contre
la famine une famine aggravée avec la
pandémie de kobe 19
ce dernier informe que le nombre de
personnes qui souffrent de malnutrition
va augmenter de 80 % d'ici à la fin de
l'année un appel à l'aide est lancé aux
donateurs internationaux
les six prochains mois seraient
déterminants
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
beaucoup de l'avoir suivi prochain point
sur l'actualité dans un peu plus de
trente minutes excellentes soirées avec
nous sur arte france
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien que difficiles qui avait
une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour
nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mines de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde tape